this tower windmill is located near
Berlin in the village of hazel off
whenever he can
urban Hoopa stops by hello come on in
Hoopa always wanted to live in a
windmill he's decorated his kitchen with
team homeware and antique finds
the spacious kitchen is the windmills
ground floor there are five storeys
above it
when Hoopa bought the 19th century
windmill 25 years ago it was in ruins
the carpenters spent more than a decade
fixing it up but all the work was worth
it in the end
the interior design at the kitchen and
bathroom had to be customized because of
the windmills round walls iPhone I even
a woman it was really a great moment
when you could finally take a shower
here before there was just a garden hose
in the summertime midwinter there was
nothing that's what he the wasn't it
Corbin hoopla is also a trained Miller
when he bought the mill he wanted to get
it up and running again by restoring its
machinery that included the mills cap
which sits at the top of the tower well
in haven't realized there call this kind
of Dutch windmill has a rotating top
that means that what we're standing on
rotates in sits on top of bearings wand
dolly
uh deposits on the Munya so when you
pass by the mill the top is always
facing in a different direction stairs
like they'll call depending on from
which direction the wind is blowing a
copy of plain
the wind is what powers all the cogs in
the mill Liam yeah this is the wind
shaft on which the windmills blades are
mounted they're facing in this direction
there's a huge wheel that's turned by
the blades with influenza PM border one
below you can maybe see a cog that's
attached to another shaft I know that
runs through the whole windmill and
powers its machines gateways console
holes on pipeline installation and
machine
Hoopa has to make sure too much wind
doesn't get trapped in the blades and he
also has to keep the towers cap firmly
anchored so it doesn't fly off
my college met mine from the internet
compared to a normal family home there's
always something to do here you have to
keep the shafts oiled repaint the blades
tighten the screws repair the brackets
it always keeps you busy on the third
floor of the mill Hoopa has opened up a
small museum many objects in its
collection are from the early 20th
century almost all of them have
something to do with mills or the
milling trade
let's give occasionally I do an open
house more a group might tell me they
want to visit and take a tour here from
Abu Klea cousin like the Sun called
Hooper's bedroom is on level 2 of the
tower it was once the mill floor who has
kept the mill stone intact here behind
you theoretically I could grind corn
here you dip it down the funnel there
and if the wind were blowing you could
grind corn wine Titus Horton but all
that grain would make hoopa's bedroom
incredibly dusting instead the Miller
spends his time making kites from old
umbrellas 160 were needed to make this
one
not him take care bye-bye
Obon Hoopa compares his windmill to one
of his kites he's simply a man who's
driven by the wind